Even though it’s already three hours long,
not all of Avengers: Endgame made it to the
screen.
Some of the deleted scenes are probably best
left on the cutting room floor, while others
might've made the movie even better.
From goji berries to a tearful farewell, here
are the scenes you didn't get to see.
One of the six deleted Avengers: Endgame scenes
is ordinary but unintentionally hilarious
for a few reasons.
Titled "Goji Berries," the moment takes us
inside Pepper Potts and Tony Stark's lakeside
cabin, where they're living in married bliss
and discussing fairly unexciting things...like
alpacas and berries.
"First of all, Gerald is our alpaca."
"He's not my alpaca if he's eating my gojis."
"Okay, they're gonna be nice in the salad
right there."
"No, don't!
Don't!
The scene is extra humorous considering Paltrow's
real-life love of health, wellness, and cooking.
As some Marvel fans may know, Paltrow owns
the natural health company Goop, which sells
clothes, shoes, supplements, and yes, even
goji berries.
Another deleted Avengers: Endgame scene references
the events at the end of Captain America:
The First Avenger.
Bearing the title "Bombs on Board," the sequence
features James "Rhodey" Rhodes and Steve Rogers
running through what happened to the Tesseract
after Cap crashed a Hydra aircraft in The
First Avenger.
The Tesseract, which the present-day Avengers
were looking to find as part of their time
heist mission, fell out of the plane and sank
to the bottom of the ocean during the crash.
"Why did you have to crash the plane, anyway?"
"Bombs on board."
So Rhodey asks the obvious question:
"And you couldn't have jumped out of the plane
before you crashed it?"
Seriously, why didn't he jump out?
That's one moment where Rogers could take
a good, hard look at his past self and say...
"That is America's ass."
A silly and unfinished scene cut from the
theatrical version of Avengers: Endgame features
Rocket Raccoon sitting with surviving members
of the Avengers crew at the team's headquarters.
Gathered around a table, the heroes watch
some footage from the Avengers' fight against
the Chitauri in the 2012 Battle of New York,
as seen in the first Avengers film.
Rocket asks how long Earth's Mightiest Heroes
fought, and Black Widow responds, "About two,
two or three hours."
The snarky raccoon is shocked that the Avengers
spent that much time in battle with the aliens.
"The Chitauri are the suckiest army in the
galaxy.
Why didn't you just blow up the mothership?"
Rocket gets a good laugh out of how inept
the Avengers were, but, of course, Tony Stark
always gets the last laugh.
"You didn't know that was a thing?
Everyone knows…"
In another deleted scene that still has some
early CGI, Rocket and Thor in his "Fat Thor"
state are back in the year 2013, lurking through
the halls of the Asgardian Palace.
The two are trying to determine which path
to take to avoid the Dark Elves' attack and
retrieve the Reality Stone to take back to
2023.
Unfortunately, the god of thunder is of little
help when Rocket asks which way to go.
After urinating off the side of a palace wall
to the floor below, Thor says that he's not
coping well with being back in Asgard during
the time in which he witnessed so much death.
He admits he doesn't know the correct path
to safety, but Rocket doesn't appreciate the
honesty.
"You used to frickin' live here!"
"For 1,500 years, not forever.
That way I think.
Yeah, maybe."
"We are dead.
We are so, so dead."
The scenes between Tony Stark and his distant
father Howard Stark were some of the most
heartwarming ones in Avengers: Endgame.
However, a small moment left out of the final
film would have inspired even more fuzzy feelings.
As the father-son duo are walking through
the 1970s S.H.I.E.L.D. base while discussing
the fears that come with first-time fatherhood
and the importance of leaving a legacy, Howard
gives Tony an offer that must have been hard
to refuse.
But Tony doesn't miss a beat with his reply.
"You wanna come work for me, Potts?"
"I'm a little tied up in futures right now."
Get it?
Because he's from the future?
Anyway, it's a brief little moment, but we'll
take all the Stark family bonding we can get.
"Thank you for everything you've done for
this country."
While the rest of the deleted Avengers: Endgame
scenes are all under a minute long, the final
one comes in at almost two minutes.
The heftiest sequence both in terms of emotion
and length, the "Avengers Take a Knee" scene
happens immediately after Tony Stark sacrifices
his life in the battle against Thanos.
As Tony slips away, Pepper Potts kisses his
cheek while the Avengers look on and realize
the weight of what just happened.
Hawkeye drops to one knee and places his head
against his hand to honor the fallen Avenger
who started the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
This sparks a chain reaction, and one by one
the rest of the heroes kneel in respect.
We even catch a shot of the 2014 Gamora looking
on, almost contemplating kneeling before turning
and walking away.
Maybe she's going to hang out with Deadpool
in the non-kneeling clubhouse.
"You know, that's really hard on your knees.
Totally impractical.
They all do it."
This deleted scene is impactful, but let's
be honest: the theatrical scene was already
heartbreaking enough.
Adding this into the mix would have left everyone
full-on sobbing into their popcorn.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.